L'Europe, c'est le
premier marché au monde.
Donc nous avons une force,
nous avons une puissance.
L'autonomie stratégique,
il faut déjà savoir ce que c’est.
c'est avoir son destin entre les mains,
de ne pas dépendre des autres.
Donc en fait,
pour tous les éléments
sur lesquels nos chaînes de valeur
sont dégradées, sur lesquelles
nous avons des dépendances,
il faut trouver une solution,
une autonomie stratégique.
Ça peut être la défense,
ça peut être l'énergie
ça peut être l'industrie aussi.
On a vu, notamment
pendant la crise du COVID,
que les médicaments
étaient fabriqués à 80% en Asie
et qu'il valait mieux rapatrier
ces éléments là chez nous pour qu'en
cas de crise, on puisse soigner les gens.
Il y a plein de domaines comme ça
sur lesquels l'automobile stratégique peut s'appliquer.
J'ajouterais peut être l'espace aussi,
puisque avec un accès autonome
à l'espace et à des vrais satellites européens,
nous sommes sûrs de notre destin
et de ne pas dépendre
des technologies d'autres continents.
Alors la décarbonation a un double intérêt :
ça permet de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique,
mais également de produire local
et donc de réduire nos importations
d'énergies dans l'Union européenne.
Maintenant, avec la décarbonation,
on va pouvoir produire local :
de l'éolien, du solaire, de l'hydraulique, de l'osmotique
et certain nombre d'autres énergies,
notamment les énergies hydroliennes.
Nous allons réussir à créer
une nouvelle dynamique
avec un soutien financier européen
et à ce prix là,
on aura vraiment une énergie décarbonée
et en autonomie stratégique européenne.
L'autonomie stratégique,
cela va clairement passer
par renforcer notre production électrique
à l'intérieur de l'Union européenne.
Donc, on produit notre énergie chez nous.
On développe beaucoup de partenariats
avec beaucoup de pays
sur des petites quantités
et donc là, on n'est pas en dépendance
et donc on peut renforcer
notre autonomie stratégique
et atteindre ce grand objectif
qu'est le Green Deal, en 2050.
C'est le Pacte Vert qui va nous permettre
d'être neutre en émissions de CO2
par rapport à 1990
et donc de contribuer à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique.
Merci l'Europe de lutter
On est le premier continent au monde à le faire.